- [Mark] All right, Diamond.
- Hi, Mark.
- [Mark] Welcome back.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Great to see you again.
- It's always good to see me, I think.
- [Mark] (chuckles) You're always modest.
- Well, I enjoy myself.
- [Mark] So we had a nice talk last time,
a short one but a nice one.
What do you think it is about your,
about the street life that
took you down that path?
I mean, so many young girls are into it
and they just, very few, if any of them,
are getting anywhere in life.
Yet, it's like they hang onto it.
- You're right about that.
You're right about, you know,
it's just if you don't take your money
or take what you know and use it
quick and fast,
I would say like that,
and get out, get what you
got to get and then go.
Like accomplish whatever
you need to accomplish,
whatever goal you're trying to get
and go and get out of it
because, you know, they say this,
fast money, people don't respect.
Like if you got a job doing your job,
you respect your money more
because you work hard for it.
Because our money comes so easy
and so fast, we waste it.
So we don't think about the future,
especially when you're that young.
When you're like in your teens out here,
or your early 20s,
you know, all you see is the cliche.
You see what, um,
I would say, the rappers,
the TV, you know,
you try to keep up with them,
and lord knows, you can't,
'cause first of all, you got
this pimp on the side of here,
you got your family over here,
and you really, really don't want
nobody to know what you're doing
'cause you're not even in
the area that you live in doing it.
- [Mark] And it seems
like everybody around you,
including yourself, is
doing something devious.
- Oh my god, devious is part of the game.
- [Mark] It is the game.
- It's a major part of it.
- [Mark] Everyone's scamming everybody.
- It's all about illusion.
It's one big scam, that's what it is.
Because my job is not to do it, you know.
My job is to get the money
out of you the best way I can
without doing little of nothing.
All I have to do is suit up and show up,
and they 'posed to follow.
So, I don't know, but,
I haven't had too many problems
with my job description.
I get a few bumps in the road because
I deal with mothafuckas that ain't shit,
so that makes me become part
of that ain't-shit crew.
- [Mark] Have you ever worked with a pimp?
- Negative.
- [Mark] No.
- For what?
Why would I need to give my
money to somebody else? Okay.
I know how to manage my
money just right, okay.
- [Mark] Now, you're one of nine siblings.
- Yes I am, I'm the oldest.
I need an ashtray Mark.
- [Mark] The floor.
- Oh, floor, okay.
- [Mark] Did any of your siblings
get into the street life?
- No, and I wouldn't suggest them to.
All my sisters are squares, you know,
mothers, and go to school, go to college.
They live a normal life.
Other than getting drunk
and doing normal shit.
- [Mark] When you guys
get together do they...
- Oh, when we get together it's a blast.
- [Mark] they laugh and roll their eyes?
- Oh my god, no, roll their eyes?
I am loved, very much so.
I'm the big sister.
They love and respect me to the fullest.
So, you know, they like my pocket too.
They like to call me and
ask for money sometimes too.
Like it grows on trees or something.
But anyhow.
- [Mark] What do you
think it was about your
genetic makeup or your
environment, or what?
Something took you down
this path instead of...
- Well, we discussed that before.
I was intrigued by the look.
What it looked like on the outside.
You know, the dress up, the
makeup, the fantasy look.
I was intrigued by that.
At 13, you're easily to be
influenced by a lot of things,
and coming from nothing
to wanting something,
and this looked like, oh my god,
look, they're pretty, they dress up.
You know, that's what got my attention,
basically, the look.
I had no clue what I was
in store for, whatsoever.
But yeah, but anyways.
- [Mark] You didn't have a
whole lot of other alternatives.
I mean, glamor to you was
the streets rather than
maybe going to an expensive shopping area
and working in a store or doing something.
- Well, I didn't feel the need
to have to go work so hard
in a store when I was gonna
make this amount of money
in these amount of minutes
or these amount of seconds,
compared to the store,
every two weeks pay.
I mean what the fuck does that sound like?
That didn't sound too
good to me at the time.
- [Mark] The fast money
becomes too tempting, huh?
- I mean, shit, money's tempting anyways.
It's the root of all evil.
- [Mark] It's an interesting career
because you're people skills must get
really developed quickly, right?
Because you have to get
along really, really well
and have intimate relationships
with all kinds of strangers.
- Intimate?
Ain't nobody do nothing intimate.
Shit, what the fuck?
Let me put this cigarette out Mark.
The floor, okay.
Intimate, that funny.
- [Mark] You have to get
along with everybody.
- Well, of course.
You gotta have swag and people skills
in order to, you know,
it's like in a store,
don't be working behind that cash register
if you ain't gonna be
smiling on the other side.
- [Mark] Were there nights where you just
didn't want to do it?
You weren't in the mood
and had to tolerate these...
- I'm never in the mood,
never, none of the nights.
- [Mark] You're never in the mood?
- I'm always in the mood for the one thing
and that's the dollars.
You know, I think big.
I like everything.
I got champagne taste
with peanut butter money.
So, I'm always thinking big.
I always want something better.
I got too many damn habits
that are very expensive
that must be taken care of.
- [Mark] Has your view of
men changed over the years?
You've been doing this a long time.
- Well, you know, men are men.
Men feed me, clothe me, provide for me.
So you know, without them, hey,
I wouldn't be able to survive today.
Pay bills, to pay rent.
You know, they are my, I would say,
how you say it?
I guess I'm their co-worker.
Are they my boss?
Shit, they pay me, my pay.
That's how we'll put that.
They pay me, and they pay me good.
And I'm good too, as much as I can be.
- [Mark] And you love men? You hate men?
You tolerate them?
- I love men.
I love men and what they do for me.
I love what they do for me.
They do a lot of things
for me that I need, shit.
- [Mark] Do you have kids?
- My kids?
- I got five kids, and I'm a grandma.
- [Mark] Really?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] wow.
And you raise your kids?
I can't remember.
- No, I didn't raise my children.
My mother raised my children for me.
I only raise my children
through financial.
No, I didn't get the option
to raise my kids because,
the path I took in my life didn't allow me
to have kids in my environment.
My environment is not for no kids.
My environment is not for
anybody that doesn't have a
strong stomach, period.
If you ain't got guts, and...
I mean, my environment is
not safe for a lot of people
that doesn't know what they're doing.
I can't explain this shit, Mark.
It's hard to explain.
You be asking me shit
that I can't explain,
but I will try to explain
the best way I can.
Shit, my environment
is just my environment,
and I'm a part of my environment.
I don't have to be in my environment.
I could choose to do other
things if I choose to.
You know, because I'm not dumb or stupid.
I'm a little goofy sometimes.
But other than that,
I could choose to get out of
this lifestyle if I want to.
It's not easy, I'm not gonna say that.
It's not easy at all.
You're just, you know, retiring.
Because you go from making
this to try and make that,
and the struggle is like,
with me it's the struggle.
I don't like to struggle
because I'm a worry wart,
so struggling for me is like,
I ain't gonna be able to do it, you know,
'cause it makes pressure,
and it causes me to do things that
I know I shouldn't be doing.
So, I don't like to struggle.
So, I don't think I'll be
able to do a nine-to-five job.
I would like to own my
own business one day.
And I do have a lot of
skills in a lot of areas
as far as schooling.
I'm not stupid.
I didn't finish school, but
I didn't stop there either.
I don't know.
Mark, ask me something interesting.
- [Mark] If you had your
life to live all over again?
- I wouldn't change it.
- [Mark] You wouldn't?
- For what?
It might turn out worse
than it already is.
- [Mark] So you have no regrets?
- No regrets.
No, not yet.
Some of these niggas I be
picking, I be regretting.
But besides that, I don't got no regrets.
My life is what it is,
and I don't cry about spoiled milk,
and I don't worry about the
woulda, shoulda, couldas,
and the why and the why nots.
I just go with the flow, Mark,
because hey, I'm just here.
I'm just here doing what
I have to do to survive,
to eat, sleep, and shit,
and guess what,
I do what I gotta do
by all means necessary.
- [Mark] I think you're the only woman
that works the streets who
referred to being raped
as that's part of the job.
- [Diamond] It is part of the job.
You jumping out of cars of
mothafuckas you don't know.
You better be expect
anything to happen, you know.
Hey, shit.
People that don't work the street
are at risk for being raped.
So you put yourself at
risk working the street.
You put yourself at
risk working the street
for all kinds of shit.
You get subject to all kinds
of shit to happen to you,
but that's your choice you made
if this the job that you want.
- [Mark] I was there last night,
and I see these girls wearing these
crazy short dresses and high heels.
- [Diamond] Oh, I ain't
dressing like that because see,
I'm not gonna show off all my shit
so they get free nuts.
- [Mark] But they're jumping
into cars with strangers
that they've never met before.
They don't know who this guy is.
- [Diamond] Yeah, Jeffrey
Dahmer. (laughing)
- [Mark] Absolutely.
John Wayne Gacy is driving
by in a pickup truck.
- [Diamond] All these mothafuckas, yeah.
(coughing) Coronavirus,
no I'm just kidding.
(laughing)
- [Mark] So, where does
your life go from here?
- [Diamond] How would I know
where my life goes from here Mark?
I ain't fuckin' psychic.
I ain't related to Cleo no kinda way.
- [Mark] You can't do this forever.
- [Diamond] Shit, I would
hope I don't have to.
I would hope some day somebody will come
and sweep me off my pretty feet.
- [Mark] And take care of you.
- [Diamond] Yes.
I need somebody to take care of me,
my back be hurting sometime.
- [Mark] You need a man to rub your feet.
- [Diamond] I need a man
to rub everything baby,
especially my pockets.
Especially my pockets,
'cause they hurtin' like
a mother fucker right now.
Coronavirus is kicking my ass
and everybody around me.
- [Mark] You've been in love before?
- Yeah, I'm in love now.
I don't wanna talk about that
'cause he gets on my fucking nerve too.
I don't wanna talk about no niggas.
I swear I don't.
Shit, let's go back to me.
- [Mark] What's your favorite
quality about yourself?
Personality trait.
- Oh, shit.
I have so many.
Let me think.
My favorite.
- [Mark] You like yourself?
- I love myself, shit.
I'm good to me, you know.
It took me a long time to
learn how to be good to me.
So, I didn't learn how to
be good to me overnight.
So, today, as we speak today,
oh yeah, can't nothing about me
discourage me from doing what I need to do
because I have faith in me in all I do,
and I will succeed at whatever
I do because that's the plan.
Okay, since we have
nothing to talk about Mark,
I'm done with this interview.
- [Mark] (laughing) Okay,
Diamond, thank you very much.
Great seeing you again.
- You're welcome, any time.
The pleasure's all mine.